tous contre le sida près de 20 millions
de téléspectateurs face à leur
télévision hier soir pour regarder la
première émission réaliser toutes
chaînes confondues
plus de 50 millions de francs aussi
recueilli 1994 première soirée du
sidaction organisé grâce au combat de la
chanteuse line renaud la lutte contre le
sida occupe le devant de la scène avec
un message porté notamment par les
artistes c'est évident et 10
on est tous concernés ce cri du coeur
il est d'abord porté par les
associations dès la fin des années 80
elle j'estime que le monde politique
n'en fait pas assez contre le sida
la france est le pays le plus touché en
europe on a le double de pâques par
exemple l'allemagne l'angleterre et on a
après après dix ans encore d'aider des
préjugés ou des peur à l'idée de faire
des grandes campagnes de prévention les
associations se mobilisent à travers de
grandes manifestations qu'ils restent
dans les mémoires
le sidaction en 1994 mais également les
actions d'act up six ans capote
l'obélisque de la concorde en 1993 où se
livre à des jeans comme ici en 1990 la
vingtaine de manifestants se couche
devant l'entrée de la rue qui conduit au
domicile privé du président de la
république
à la surprise générale autre action
médiatique l'intrusion dans un lycée
comme ici à paris en 1992
l'objectif des militants d'act-up parler
du préservatif et militer pour la
généralisation de son usage et tu te
tard
besoin il faudrait qu'on en parle un peu
plus ces mêmes associations diffuse
d'alors des spots télévisés très
explicite mais l'action des associations
se fait aussi à travers des opérations
sur le terrain comme dans les
discothèques amiens bastia ou ici à
strasbourg en 1991
des militants de l'association aides
viennent à la rencontre des jeunes pour
faire de la prévention
sauf que le lieu est très bien choisi
parce que c'est difficile de civils de
trouver un endroit où il y beaucoup de
jeunes à la fois la décennie 90 marquée
par la mobilisation sans précédent des
associations pour la lutte contre le
sida se termine par un festival en 1999
l'association solidarité sida organise
le festival solidays plus de 80 mille
festivaliers viennent écouter hip hop
robbie williams aux asie entre 1983 et
l'épidémie de sida aura causé la mort
d'environ 30000 personnes en france
[Musique]